businesses making less than $10 million
per year cannot afford to make this
mistake and it's a problem that limited
me and my ability to sell my company but
when I fixed it I was able to sell it
for $ 46.2 million and there are four
steps to solving this problem to avoid
This calamity and lots of blood and
death and it all starts with number one
keyman risk a single person that is
vital to the operations of the business
and if they were gone the business would
decrease materially in the amount of
money that it makes or disappear
altogether and so think about it like
this you've got these functions that
occur in the business on a regular basis
and there may be multiple people that
can do these functions and so the
opposite of keyman risk is redundancy
meaning if one of these people disappear
we still have a flow for let's say
dollars to go across this bridge it can
still keep kind of make its way through
but all of a sudden if you've got one
here and it doesn't matter how many
different redundancies you have in the
rest of the system if this goes away
there's no way else for the dollars or
the customers to move across and
hopefully into your pocket that's my
little pocket for you why this matters
is that if you have keyman risk you
don't have an asset you have a
high-paying job and I don't say that to
insult you I say that so that you can be
aware of it so that you can actually fix
it and to be clear if you are fine just
working and not necessarily owning an
asset that's great there's nothing wrong
with trading time for money big fan and
so so I'll give you an example when I
had gym launch I was kind of the
innovator of the product and the service
and so I came up with the solutions for
the gyms and so for an acquirer or a
private Equity Firm who wants to buy
this business or whoever else you might
want to sell a business too having one
person especially if it's the person
who's going to leave when the business
is sold is a huge massive red flag for
them because they're like wait we're
buying this production but it's with
this key cog in the machine and you want
to have us buy this thing and remove the
Cog now in a situation where you raise
money for example it's not as much of an
issue because those people those pieces
those cogs are still in the machine if
you wanted to sell a company and you own
the company and you leave and all the
people who are still keyman remain
within the business then what they're
going to do is try and incentivize those
people to stay but it still makes the
company sellable so this just counts
double if it's the owner or somebody
who's going to leave as a result of a
transaction
is the keyman risking any of the
functions of the business so I was
keyman in the delivery and so I did a
couple things to solve the problem so
number one is that I created a
department called the R&D department and
so the way it worked was simple I
thought about the process that I would
go through when I wanted to innovate the
product so I'd say okay what can we do
for our gym owners that will help them
generate more leads make more sales
whatever the issue was and so the first
thing that I did was that I would say
okay I have a way of identifying
problems and so I would ask the
customers and the nice thing is if you
listen to your customers they will shout
at you and they will tell you exactly
what their problems are and so I'd say
Okay number one is that I had these
problems now I have to solve those
problems and so I'd have them rank the
problems they say okay this month lead
generation is the biggest issue they
want more leads and I'd say all right
now the next thing that I would do is I
would deploy resources so this would be
time and money that ideally my customers
couldn't deploy but I could
fractionalize that cost between all of
my customers to create a much bigger
individual investment that any one of
them could afford and so let's say they
pay $3 or $4,000 a month I would spend
$50,000 a
month on this test and so I'd say okay
go hire a bunch of models go out to a
really good gym film some great ads then
test Those ads so number three I would
test the ads in representative Market
markets so I'd have 20 markets or so
that would represent different
demographics so black white asian
Hispanic poor markets Rich markets large
markets small markets with good
operators with poor operators with
mediocre operators that way I had a true
sampling rather than just saying I'm
just going to send this to my favorite
customers because that's not going to
work and so we test it and then what I
would do is hand off winners and so what
that meant was I would say okay these
ads of the 30 that we ran and we spent
$50,000 on this whole thing these two or
three were the ones that generated the
highest returns and then I would give
all of those to the gyms in our
distribution base so that they could run
those ads they just wanted the inputs to
feed the system and those inputs were
required on a regular basis in order for
me to hand this off to someone I said
this is fundamentally the way I do it I
look at the problems that they have in
this instance it was lead generation I
would dedicate time time and money to
solving this problem in a way that they
couldn't do it so that I could create a
better solution that they could do it on
their own I would test to validate that
the solution that I had was Superior and
then we roll it out and I followed this
process for my R&D so that I could
replicate the person with a system and
so typically keyman risk will occur in
three primary areas so number one is
that it can occur in marketing so how do
we get leads in the door the second big
place that it can occur is sales or
conversion how do we get prospects to
hand US money for our goods and services
and then third is the actual goods and
services themselves which you can
consider product Etc this happens at any
level so if you're a service and you're
just happen to be the best plumber or
the best electrician or you're the best
coder or you're the best Advertiser now
with marketing for example if you own a
marketing agency you probably your key
man on marketing for yourself and
marketing for your customers right like
it can happen in multiple places even if
it's one person and in the and the more
places one person is keyman the riskier
the business is overall now I want to be
clear keyman risk is a double-edged
sword because the more valuable you
become more of a key man you are and so
the idea is that as soon as you learn a
very valuable skill the most valuable
thing that you can do next is learn how
to transfer that skill to another person
and I think this is a skill that I've
spend a tremendous amount of time trying
to hone so that I can build companies
and I think about it like this assemble
companies assemble people and then
transfer the skills around whatever area
has some sort of bottleneck where
there's too few people people who know
how to do the thing and this is so
important because whether you want to
sell a business or not making a business
that is sell a bull makes it better for
anyone here's the best analogy I have
say that you've bought a house now if
you've never bought a house before then
this may be news but when you buy a
house what happens is that after a
certain amount of time and the average
American like three to five years they
they they change where they live all
right so you buy a house now over time
you got some wear and tear on the house
and the house kind of degrades in your
mind right like that you get a little
crack on the front porch this this door
kind of squeaks a little bit and when
you go to sell what do you do well you
fix the you fix the little path in front
of the house you put some oil on the
little hinges here you know you're like
you know what maybe I'll put a little
patio out back I feel like that would
increase our home value right and then
all of a sudden and this is the crazy
thing right when you're about to sell
the house and you fixed all the things
that are wrong with it you're like you
know this house ain't so bad right and
so the same exact thing happens with the
business if all of a sudden you remove
yourself as keyman in marketing and
sales and product all of a sudden you're
like
huh this business almost runs without me
this ain't so bad now the last area that
you can have keyman risk that can occur
and this is kind of like the glue
between all of
these
is operations so if you have a key
leader for example who has tremendous
influence over the entire team then the
operations connects the people to their
functions and so think of that as kind
of the glue that runs the organization
like if ilila were to leave she would
leave a huge vacuum at acquisition.
comom now she's not specifically over
Marketing sales or product she just has
all of these leaders that are rolling
into her and so if the leadership was
gone that in and of itself would also be
somebody who's key man and to be clear
key man is Key Human so it doesn't have
to be a Founder it can be an employee
who can be keyman and if you do have
someone who's keyman in your business
and it's your business and not theirs
then it would behoove you if they're
truly key man to incentivize them in
some material way to stay so if you're
thinking to yourself okay this is me I'm
definitely keyman or there's somebody in
my business who's keyman on Marketing
sales operations product then there are
two major ways that you can solve this
so the first is through process and
people just like I walked through
earlier where I said okay what are the
actual steps that I do in order to solve
this marketing problem what are the
actual steps that I use use to think
through creating new products what are
the actual steps that I use to think
through creating sales process driving
sales results Etc so it's process and
the people who will then do those
processes within the business the second
way and this really only applies if it's
not you who is the person who's keyman
is
incentives and so if it's
you you only have option one if it's
somebody else other people you have
option one and option to to solve the
problem and so for example if I said hey
I will incentivize you to stay in this
business by giving you some vesting of
shares over a three or 5e period then
that would make it less likely that the
person's going to leave and disrupt the
business I think through it in both of
these now which of these is the most
valuable like most valuable to the
business to do well the most valuable to
do is this one but the higher up the
skill set is the more unique the
individual like think about Elon Musk
he's key man in almost all of his
businesses but the reason that it's okay
is that he has no desire to sell them
and so people bet on Elon and the
companies they bet on Jeff basos and the
the businesses because they are
inseparable entities like they go one
together and no one's leaving right they
got public and all of their Shares are
still theirs and they're still
incentivized to continue to grow it now
if you're watching this and wondering
well okay processing people what does
that actually mean so ins inside $100
million leads I break this down so in
the employees section which is a chapter
in the book in terms of how to help how
to get people to get you more customers
you have the functions that an employee
would do and so there's two aspects one
is like how do I get these people and so
you can use warm Outreach to ask your
network you can do cold Outreach which
is basically recruiting you can post
content which is basically posting job
openings that you have available doing
paid ads so promoting job postings on
like a Craigslist or an indeed or a
monster or a ladder getting employee
referrals right so rather than customer
referrals you're getting employee
referrals Affiliates would be like
associations guilds list serves that
already have a huge amount of people who
want this specific type of roller job
agency so think like staffing firms and
then obviously employees themselves uh
could be could be the solution now how
do you get them to actually do this and
so the step one is that you document
which is basically saying hey here's our
checklist of things that must occur in
order for this process to be deemed
complete or sufficient the second D here
is demonstrate which is that you do it
in front of them right so you do it on
your own and you create the checklist
then you do that checklist in front of
them and you only stick with that
checklist because if you do anything off
the checklist then you have to add to it
and then finally you they do it in front
of you so they duplicate it so you
document checklist you demonstrate it in
front of them then they demonstrate it
in front of you which is basically
duplication and so that three-step
process is fundamentally how you can
teach anyone to do anything and in order
to make a process more teachable you
simply have to break it down to more and
more steps based on the skill of the
person you're teaching it to if I wanted
to teach an advanced marketer how to do
email marketing for example I wouldn't
say hey turn on your computer step two
pull up Internet Explorer step three
sign up for a Gmail account right I
wouldn't have to go through all those
steps because there's an assumed level
of proficiency this is why when you go
to college or whatever education system
you went through there are prerequisites
for moving on to the next level so that
they don't have to teach you arithmetic
and then teach you calculus later they
just assume you know it and so your
checklist that you create is going to
depend on the level of the person that
you're teaching the skill to and the
lower the level the more checks you're
going to be on the list the more you
need to regress it and so let's say you
brought on somebody for sales right
who's going to be a director of sales
this might be a higher level world you
would still follow the same thing as hey
these are the activities that I spend my
time on this is what I actually do then
they're going to watch you do it you
probably are running teams you're
probably doing one-on ones you're
probably looking at data to look for key
out points so that you can address them
and solve them within the team and then
they are going to take over those
responsibilities do them in front of you
and then when they have done them to the
satisfactory level you can then delegate
it and so the easy litmus test for good
delegation is that after you've given
the responsibility away and someone else
is actually doing the actions then the
performance of the department or
function either remains neutral or goes
up that is when you have successfully
delegated it's not that you give
something to someone that makes it
delegation you can give something to
someone and completely abdicate or
basically get rid of responsibility but
with no feedback loop to determine
whether or not you did a good job or
that they're doing a good job and so it
has to be the performance of the
function after you've handed off that
determines whether or not you have
successfully delegated and sometimes you
have to repeat the cycle multiple times
with the same person and that's okay
because you need to learn to on how to
teach better and quick Pro tip if you're
a smaller business and let's say that
you do some sort of service and it's
just you or just you and a couple people
there are three options that you can do
when you have too much demand and very
fixed amount of Supply like you can't
you can't you're you're completely maxed
out you can't take on any more customers
you barely can't so option one is that
you can simply raise your prices and if
you do that you'll absolutely make more
money so you'll get paid more for the
same thing which is my favorite way of
getting paid now the second thing that
you can do is you can increase the
service ratio and so that means instead
of doing oneon-one for example I would
do one on five or one on 10 now
alternatively you can think of it with a
team the same way which is let's say I
have four people who work in my agency
and they do different functions to serve
one type of customer then if I can
change it from those four people
together can handle 20 clients I could
have those four people together handling
40 clients and so the ratio still shifts
towards us so you get more efficient
which is either process or some sort of
technology or training that allows you
to get more from your existing Talent
the third and this is the most valuable
one is that you do
this processing people is that you
actually get somebody else to do the
work for you which typically means you
have to organize the stuff make sure
they they did it successfully and you
can hand it off now these two things
both make you more money this one helps
you eliminate the actual problem of
keyman risk and if I had to do this in
sequence meaning in what order would I
do this first is I would raise prices
because that requires the least amount
of work and can immediately make me
money if I'm Supply constrained second I
would say okay well people are saying
yes to these higher prices well I don't
want to raise prices again which you
obviously still can I can shift my
service ratio at this current price to
fundamentally Dude down the service that
I have because it's so good and as long
as my value still exceeds my price
without raising the price with this
second implementation I would still have
people who want to give me money now if
I've done as much of these two things as
I can I can then say you know what I
want to not have to do any of these
things at all I want someone else to do
them and then that transforms this
particular job that you have because as
an entrepreneur you'll have more than
one job it takes this job takes the hat
off your head and puts it on someone
else's and then that shifts you towards
owning an asset rather than owning a job
and to be clear I'm all for maximizing
the amount of money that you're making
and some businesses lend themselves more
to kind of the people and process stuff
than others do Taylor Swift for example
is going to have a hard time being like
hey this is my blonde double and she's
going to sing for you guys today because
look I've I've delegated the
responsibility now it's very unlikely
that that would happen and so there are
situations where you just have unicorns
in a business and so that's where you
just have to align incentives like crazy
and try and take it all the way which is
either you're just getting a paid a ton
of money which you know Taylor Swift
does or you create liquidity meaning you
you get paid for the equity shares that
you have via a different vehicle than
selling so when you go public you don't
you sell a little bit of the company but
the vast majority of the wealth that
most of those Founders have is that they
have shares that they can take loans
against the bigger a business gets if
you don't have any desire to sell you
can take debt or other instruments where
people will lend you and you can
collateralize or back it up with the
stock that you have in the business and
so if you don't pay them back they get
to own shares in the company if you are
keyman in your business or someone else
in your business is keyman help me
spread the word with this because these
mes cost me so dearly that I hope that
it prevents everyone else from making
them that way we can all ride into the
sunset into our amazing businesses that
are risk-free and making all the money
in the entire world so if you could hit
the share button and send it to friends
and family and even enemies for you know
I mean like hey they need help too or
friend ofies maybe a little bit safer
than it would me in the world otherwise
enjoy the rest of it so now that we
covered keyman risk the next mistake
that business owners under 10 million
doll make is single Channel risk now
that's just a fancy word so let me tell
you what it means if more than half of
your customers or leads come from one
place you have single Channel risk and
the concept behind this is that if that
were to stop it would materially affect
your business on a long time Horizon so
quick illustration one of our portfolio
companies which is the teeth whing chain
got a lot of business from outbound
almost all customers were coming from
that specific Source all of a sudden the
rules on that platform changed based on
the way that we could message almost
overnight we had 50 to 70% few sales
coming in from that primary channel that
is single Channel risk can you imagine
as a business owner over overnight
you're like oh my God this real change
if you're ads dependent let's say the
way that you get customers is on meta
ads and then you you lose your account
boom all of a sudden your business
almost goes to zero or if you have an
organic content following and you're
only on one platform for example and
that platform bans you or restricts you
or Shadow bands whatever and then boom
all of your lead flow disappears or you
have let's say a domain or a server that
you send your emails from when you do
outbound and all of a sudden that gets
whacked with some sort of you go into
the promotions tab on email all of a
sudden all your response rates from your
domain go to almost nothing in each of
those scenarios you have single Channel
risk now thankfully for this particular
business I had spent the last 6 months
or more building out a recurring Revenue
stream and I I detailed that in a
different video where we went from like
5% of Revenue being uh recurring Revenue
to over 60% of Revenue being recurring
Revenue even though we decreased the
amount of new sales coming in by over
half it didn't actually change our
overall Revenue because we had so much
compounding that had started to become
unlocked which is why there are multiple
ways to stabilize a business but for the
purpose of this video if you have only
one way to get customers then you have
one way to lose them so if you have
Facebook ads that are running in this
boat and this is how you get your little
fishies there's our little fishy from
Facebook and then this thing breaks all
of a sudden
you've got no fish and then you would be
very sad and then you would jump
overboard and die very sad for you and
your family and you know peace and
blessings be upon you now let's say that
you're this other guy and you said you
know what I have seen this happen before
because I've had account shut down from
organic from paid or domains that that
don't work out anymore for for cold
outbound but you know what I've made
YouTube organic I've got ads I've got
email outbound let's say we also have
Instagram content or organic okay so
let's say that our our same our same
issue happens with Facebook boom this
guy loses the fish here now this fish is
very happy because he's not going to die
and get eaten all right but but we still
have all these other fish that are
coming in from the other channels and so
this guy is still like you know what I
still do have a little bit of a tummy
here from all the fish that I've been
eating maybe it's good for me to tighten
tighten the belts a little bit and then
I can go home and feed my family and
they've been a little chunky as well
well lately and so you know what and
farm fishing is bad and let's talk about
all sorts of political things anyways
back to it you can see the problem here
clear as day if you have one source of
getting customers you've also only got
one that needs to break in order to fail
and to show how these lessons stack
together if we only had one keyman and
then this guy dies very sad right he's
little double X's here all right Dead
all right because he had no fish if we
had a second fisherman who was on the
deck he might say you know what I'm
going to throw another line out and
maybe I'm going to catch some of these
YouTube fishies over here and at least
you'd have a shot but if you have single
Channel risk and keyman risk you're
double if you wanted to buy this
fisherman business would you well it's
like well shoot there's so many ways for
this thing to fail versus this one this
guy's got a crew of people that are all
Manning each of the the polls and so
even if
they that looks bad but if any of these
guys went down so this guy jumps
overboard right then these guys are
still like Yay I'm going to get a pay
raise hey can we get his payroll those
greedy bastards but this is
fundamentally a fishing boat that I
would have a much larger likelihood of
buying because it has a larger
likelihood of producing fish
consistently so first off who needs to
worry about this well it's more
important the bigger your business gets
the more important this is and let me
explain tactically how this works
because let's say even volatility from a
single channel is something that could
Rock the the boat figuratively if you
have a small business and let's say the
channel goes down by 20% then let's say
you've got one sales guy and his
calendar goes from 100% filled to 80%
filled not a huge deal if you have a 100
sales guys and their calendars go from
100% right to all of a sudden 20 of the
guys have completely empty calendars
that level of volatility that can occur
when you only have one channel makes it
much more difficult to do business on a
regular basis there's a variety of
solutions that I will walk you through
so number one is that if you're a tiny
business you don't need to worry about
this yet but my biggest advocate for
being a small business is that you're
going to have one primary method for
getting cold people which is usually
going to be outbound number one which is
you're reaching out to prospects who
don't know who you are two is going to
be Affiliates so again you've got third
parties that are sending you traffic
three you've got ads that are ways that
people are coming into the business
business and you've got organic so this
is going to be likely how you're going
to be getting customers now I would
recommend that you do one of these three
and then plus this now this may seem
like a little bit of a departure from
some of the things I've talked before
where one channel one Avatar one product
up to a million dollar a year and that's
true it's just that I've seen like so
many people be able to manage this it's
such high return for such low effort
that the organic that you put here is
not really to acquire customers it
actually functions more to amplify what
you're doing with these other channels
and so if you are doing outbound and
then people Google you and then they can
find a little bit of content then it's
like oh this is guy this guy has a poll
so this is a real business someone is an
affiliate or Affiliates are sending you
customers or you're trying to sell
Affiliates then just knowing that you
have some sort of presence increases the
likely they do business with you and
same thing with ads and so if you're a
small business this is going to be one
of the big ones that you're probably
going to use but the organic is just
something that you can do even one post
a week it doesn't have to be a ton just
to look like you have a pulse now if
you're a bigger business then this
becomes a much bigger deal for you the
way that we solve this is uh a
standardized process that I've now had
to jump through with a lot of companies
so the first thing we do is we Shore up
long-term nurture so long-term nurture
means a combination of making more
content and email specifically followup
because a lot of people a lot of
businesses don't do a good job following
up with leads and so they have this list
of 10,000 or 20,000 1,000 people that
have done business with them over a long
period of time or at least given them
their information if we create a Cadence
or some sort of schedule around reaching
out to those people providing value and
then occasionally presenting offers
we're going to have another stream of
customers that's coming in so think of
this as in a way another customer stream
but it's an incredibly lowrisk customer
stream that is the most profitable of
all streams and so email marketing for
example has depending on the source a
42:1 to 36:1 return on dollars it's like
oh my God like why would we not do that
so we do this to decrease our risk
increase our cash flow in the short term
to get that engine going the next engine
that I like to make sure is very strong
is my referral engine and so if I
haven't put a strong referral system in
place to get customers to send me more
customers and made sure that I'm asking
multiple times in different and creative
ways throughout the customer Journey
then I Implement that next again we're
getting more for what we put in and if
we get more that's going to increase our
cash flow without adding cost basis to
the business so it's basically think
about it it's like decreasing risk and
increasing our ability to make bets
after we've got the long-term nurture
firing and we've got the referral system
going this should give us a little bit
of padding to then invest in the second
Channel now when I say invest the way
that it typically works is that you will
see no outcome for an extended period
and then all of a sudden it will start
working and you may get frustrated in
the short term that you're not seeing
immediate results but welcome to
business you have to think long term
about the value of what a second
acquisition Channel or third acquisition
Channel means to you so number one is
that when you do the second acquisition
Channel you can immediately double sales
or more and if you double Revenue you
typically far more than double profit so
that's number one number two is that the
business itself becomes less risky so
not only are we adding revenue and
profit to the business the revenue and
profits itself is more likely to
continue and so the business itself
becomes more valuable and you can sleep
much better at night knowing that if one
of these things goes down my team is
still fed and so when we make this
investment here's one of the big no no
is you don't do two news so what does
that mean well if you're going to start
a new channel that's one new what you
don't want to do is put a new person on
a new channel because then you don't
know which new is the problem because
even if you take you and maybe you're
really good or your best person and you
put them on the new channel well there's
already the newness of the new channel
and you won't know but if it's somebody
you know who's really good then at least
we're working through the channel itself
otherwise you could be stuck paying lots
of money for a long period of time not
knowing if you're solving the right
problem which is why I'm such an
advocate for Founders to have deep
understanding of the core processes of
the business which for me are understand
how you get customers which to me
marketing and sales and understand how
you deliver value now if you wanted to
Outsource it if you wanted to Outsource
accounting if you wanted to Outsource
you know HR or payroll processing those
are things that I don't see as core to
the business you can of course bring
them in house when it cost makes sense
but in terms of the core economic engine
of the business those are the things
that you the founder the entrepreneur
want to understand intimately if I am
going to start a new channel I do these
two things first in order to give myself
some breathing room I get a little more
cash flow I get a little bit more from
what I'm already doing and then I have
one new which is the new channel and
then old person now it doesn't actually
have to be old but it's somebody that I
know all right and so this can be tough
because you're like wait wait I don't
want my original channel to go down
which is the most common thing that
happens in the situation and so my
recommendation is transfer the skill on
the first Channel first to someone else
make sure that they can handle that
without decreasing performance ideally
it goes up then and only then you can
then make the investment into the second
Channel where you're the old guy and the
channel is the new thing now if you want
to bring somebody in to help you with
this I think that's a great idea like if
you're a larger business and you're like
I can't actually just like figure out
cold outbound that's fine but you
basically have a thought partner and you
guys are working through it together
because you'll have more context on the
business overall and maybe they have
more context on the methodology that
you're going to use for the second
Channel but that merger those things
coming together where you learn a lot
about the method they learn a lot about
the context of the business both people
get better this is how I've been able to
successfully use all of these different
methods of getting customers in
different companies now that we've
covered single Channel risk the next
mistake that business owners make under
10 million is key customer risk and
we're almost there I mean you can see
this tiny little Gap here I guess we
could fall down here to our deaths but
we're going to assume that we've got
some pretty good UPS here and we can we
can make this little jump so here's a
visual to kind of make this make sense
for you if any customer or Associated
customers left tomorrow would your
Revenue drop by 20% or more now the
reason 20% is kind of the number I
choose is that most businesses run at 10
20 30 40% margins and so if you had even
a 40% margin which would be a great
margin you lose half your profit this
would be material to the business itself
and its value so I'll give you a real
business story so I had a business owner
come out to acquisition. comom who was
an agency owner and he had 10 customers
and nine of his customers were small
like Tech SEO like agency customers and
then one customer was Google itself and
he was a massive percentage of his
Revenue so for him for this example this
was actually 70% of his Revenue so if
you actually look at the meat of this
fish and you added all these little
pieces of meat in between together this
is definitely the fish that has all the
money if I'm this owner I'm like oh my
God if I if I lose this whale it's going
to kill my business I'm going to I I
won't be able to I have to let go of
half my staff certainly lose all my
profit and so this is a huge risk to the
business so there are four proven ways
to solve this problem so when this
business owner came out I said we're
going to go through all four and you're
going to pick the one that you think you
have the highest likelihood of achieving
and so if this is you this is how you
solve it so the first way you can do it
is that you simply go get more I got to
draw these fish cuz I have no idea I
have to think about how to draw these uh
these little fishies here all of a
sudden you get a bunch more minnows and
then all of a sudden by percentage man
these are ugly fish by percentage you
know what this will isn't 70% of my
business anymore so you just keep adding
minnows to your boat and then all of a
sudden you're like you know what my
minnows way outweigh my whale and so I
don't have key customer risk anymore the
second way is that you lock this whale
in to a long-term contract so just think
about this whale as signing his life
away but you get Google or whatever this
customer is to sign a threeyear a 5year
a seven-year commitment and you can add
some bonuses in in there and say you're
going to have some dedicated reps or
you're going to have some sort of
discount that might be associated with
that kind of commitment but when they do
that then it makes it more stable
because it's unlikely that they're going
to leave and if you want to be smart
about this just a little Pro tip add a
little breakup Fe because some people
are still going to back out on their
agreement and you don't want to get into
a legal battle so you want to just give
them some way in the future but just
knowing that there's this nut that
they're going to have to pay will
prolong how long they'll stay with you
and so I would probably charge somewhere
in the neighborhood of 10 to 20% of the
contract now all the stuff's negotiable
as a breakup fee so if someone has a
5-year deal then I might say you got to
pay a year uh if you're going to break
up beforehand another way of thinking
about it is saying whatever discount I
give you you're going to have to pay to
make up that discount for the entirety
of the contract in order to leave the
contract another one is that they have
to give you six or 12 months of heads up
so there's a lot of ways that you can
write terms around this with a whale to
decrease the likelihood that they leave
and disrupt the business now that's path
number two the third path is and this is
my preferred path is you just get more
damn whales and then all of a sudden you
realize you know what dude I'm in the
whale business right why was I hunting
minnows look at the meat on these guys
right and so all of a sudden you don't
try to outnumber with minnows you make
all of a sudden you just go get five six
more whales and this isn't 10% or 20% of
your business so path four is a nasty
one and for many of you if this is your
situation it may actually be the right
path and I'll tell you a story to
illustrate it so there was a recruiting
firm that I was talking to and they had
grown a decent amount and they had this
Mondo contract that was on the horizon
and so they staffed for very specific
types of engineering roles that were
difficult to find so they definitely had
a niche that they had found and they had
some big whale come to them and say hey
we want you to staff US with 20 new
employees a month which was a big
contract for this firm so this firm was
probably doing $6 $700,000 a month and
so this would be like an additional
$200,000 a month that they were going to
be able to contract through this new
whale when they were asking how should
we negotiate this deal what pricing
should we put in there I thought about
it for a long time and I was like you
know what guys I think the actual best
move is to not do this deal because they
were going to have to basically change
the fundamentals of their business their
pricing their delivery the whale
demanded so many so many custom things
that were only going to be a use case
for them and were not going to service
the rest of their customers and they had
no way of reliably acquiring the whale
so I'll explain the difference so if the
whale comes in through a tried andr
Channel then this might make a ton of
sense but if you just get a random
referral or you just meet somebody you
work from your network building your
entire business around an unsustainable
or unpredictable way of getting this
type of customer is probably not smart
now if that recruiting firm had said hey
we just got our first whale but we have
a new way of getting whales then I say
oh this is the first whale of many this
makes sense but if this is just a random
lottery ticket that falls into your lap
you have to make the decision of what
business do I really want to be in and
what customer do I really want to serve
I think that this entrepreneur just saw
dollar signs in his eyes but didn't
calculate the cost of what it would mean
to his business and the disruption of
the main economic engine that he had
spent years putting together and so path
4 is you just realized that this whale
might be someone else's customer and you
let it swim on by and the fourth one and
this one is a crazy one that I've got a
story for you is single vendor risk so
this is where one vendor so think about
any person that's a business that you
pay to help you do business is
responsible for a key function of the
business and so there's a ton of
examples of this if you have all of your
customers from SEO for example and you
have an SEO who does it for you if you
have all your you know leads from PPC or
meta ads and somebody else has all of
that taken care of but they're an
outside company that is key vendor risk
unfortunately I've had this happen a lot
all right so with Prestige Labs I had
one manufacturer who made our products
we found out that he ended up stealing
about $400,000 in cash that I had sent
so and he kept asking for early and
earlier payment on stuff um to lock in
Greater discounts and in general if I
have cash and I can guarant a 10 or 20%
return on that money then it's almost
like I could put it in the stock market
but I know for sure I'm going to get 20%
discount for sure then it's like getting
a 20% return on the money guaranteed so
I'll take those deals when they come but
kept asking for it earlier and earlier
and earlier and when we just said hey
you know what it had been enough times
we're like why don't you just send us
what you owe us in terms of product all
of a sudden he couldn't because what he
had used is he was using our cash to run
his business rather than use it as an
account for the products and raw
materials that he needed to purchase for
our account obviously that was a big no
no and we were able to thankfully like
bridge to another provider and not
really Create A disruption but for
probably a period of 6 months we were
running out of product on a regular
basis and had like 3 Monon lead times
where we had to basically make this
transition and we lost a serious amount
of Revenue and that was a big hit both
to the revenue but also just reputation
because Prestige lab sold through
Affiliates it still does sell through
affili and during that period Affiliates
were like dude we can't sell half the
products we normally do cuz you don't
have them in stock and so that was very
tough and I learned that lesson Prestige
Labs which was a sub company that I
owned at about 20 million bucks a year
and I ended up selling that in that 42
million $46 million sale uh to American
Pacific group in 2021 Allen uh was a
third company that I started and sold in
2021 which was a company that helped
brick-and mortar businesses work their
leads through automated messaging and I
didn't understand how software worked at
the time and and so I just said cool I
know this problem I'm going to go hire
an Outsource Dev team to go build me
this software stack and they did and lo
and behold here's the crazy thing no one
on my team was any bit technological or
a developer and so 100% of the
development was happening in this
outside shop what do you think the
outside shop owner did when all of a
sudden this thing that he builts doing
500,000 800,000 a million 1.2 1.5 $ 1.7
million in sales all of a sudden
magically what was once $100,000 a month
in development became 200 300 $500,000 a
month of development because he could
see how much money we were making which
is why I'm such an advocate if if you
are going to start a software company
you want that person to be inh house at
least it be key man man risk that you
can control right but instead I had a
key vendor who literally designed and
built the entire product that I was
selling and so this guy had me buy the
balls there was nothing I could do and
so I had to start building an in-house
team in parallel without trying to like
let let him know that I'm doing this cuz
obviously he could see the writing on
the wall and then he was difficult to
work with and transferring the knowledge
over and it was a nightmare that was my
second big experience with this the
third you're like you should learn this
lesson you know what sometimes it takes
me a while uh another one was and I've
had multiple with this but payment
processor so in my first book $100
million offers I talk about how I lost
my payment processor and it was this
terrible experience for me because it
was the only problem I'd ever
encountered in my life that I couldn't
save with sales because no one would
process the money tldr I was running a
national business out of a brick and
mortar store that I had in Southern
California so I'm processing payments
out of Canada I'm processing payments
out of Mexico I'm processing payments
out of the United States all over the
country and they're like wait how is
this happening out of a little brick-and
mortar store in California I didn't know
how this worked I was 25 years old and
so I broke the rules and was unaware of
it and so they they held my processing
after that happened and you only need it
to happen once for every single business
that I've had afterwards I always have
redundancies in processing meaning I
have multiple processors that are
approved spun up and can handle the
entirety of my monthly volume at a
moment's notice this is also important
from a negotiating perspective because I
only had one payment processor I had no
ability to negotiate anything in terms
of my fees as well and so having
multiple there that are approved gave me
leverage with the relationship I got
better service and if for whatever
reason some something goes down I can
switch it over in a heartbeat and not
even miss miss miss anything now I had a
second occurrence with this later on in
my career where we did have redundancies
and the here was the issue I had a
recurring Revenue business and the
payment processor acted a little bit
Shady which is why I decided to shift
away from that specific processor and
they said oh if you want to transfer
away from us that's going to cost
$150,000 and I was like what and they're
like yeah it's just a lot of work to
transfer all those things over I was
like I'm pretty sure it's a button that
you click export the thing is is what
was I going to do I had multiple
Millions a month in recurring Revenue
across thousands of customers there was
nothing I could do it was basically
extortion I paid the bill and then I got
my I got all my customer information and
I transferred it to a more ethical
provider and so I bring these stories up
because I hope that you don't have to
live through each of these let's get to
the tactics for how to actually solve
against key vendor risk and I think this
one can be so nasty because it's one of
the only times where like the person on
the other side of the table has leverage
and if you don't have a good person on
the other side like they may use it and
they may try to put you out of business
or put you just as close to getting out
of business as they I mean they
basically can just blackmail you for
your own business and the amount they
can black you blackmail you for is
proportional to how much money you got
or at least how much money they think
you got so number one rule always have
backups for just about everything that's
important so you want to think about
this in terms of acquisition conversion
product and then the layer on top of
this obviously is processing banking
anything that you do that facilitates
transactions with customers and so the
big solution and we're going to put this
in big green letters so solution number
one is redundancy right now I want to be
clear about redundancy sometimes
redundancy looks like waste but is
actually Insurance the day you need it
think about it this way if I pay for
fire insurance and my house never
catches on fire if I knew for a fact
that my house would never catch on fire
then 100% of that money is completely
wasted I literally just flushed the
money down the toilet cuz I didn't get
anything for it if my house does catch
on fire the day it catches on fire every
one of those payments will 100% worth it
I see redundancy the same way which is
that it is insurance against existential
threats to the business and these are
the things that I'm telling you when I
now that I have these things in place
it's like one I have leverage in
negotiations which is probably the more
reasonable thing that you get in terms
of short term benefits of having
redundancy the second is that you sleep
great at night knowing that your
business can't get taken down at least
from the things that you know about like
listen you can't control the unknown
unknowns but at least control the knowns
if the chickens do come home to roost
and you do have that bad day and the
bill is due then you will be grateful
that you had this redundancy in place
the second way of doing this is having
mutually ensured destruction so what
does that even mean it basically means
that if the bigger you get the bigger
you are as a percentage of their
business the more they need to keep your
business and not let you go because
basically you shift from them being uh
key vendor risk to you becoming key
customer risk for them and so it's the
shift in power basically the bigger you
get the more important you are to them
and so there's this saying in the
finance world where it's like if you owe
a bank a million dollars they own you if
you owe a bank a billion dollars you own
them right now obviously depends on the
size of the bank and things like that
but the saying kind of kind of carries
right and so you want to understand
understand what percentage of the
business their business you are and that
way if they you they get too
so this is where the size of the person
that you're working with can be kind of
a double-edged sword the small guys are
probably the guys that are most likely
to do the Shady stuff on the other hand
if you become a huge percentage of their
business you have some leverage back
towards them and so redundancy number
one mutually insured destruction number
two and here's a big one Covenant and
terms all right so I'll just
say which are just fancy ways of saying
what do we agree to kind of like key
customers because key customer and key
vendor are kind of opposite sides of the
same coin all the terms that we asked
from our customers before in the last
section for mistakes we also can ask now
as the customer of the vendor so we say
hey if you want to stop doing business
with us you have to give us a 6 or 12
month lead time to letting us know that
that's going to occur so that we can
find another vendor so this number one
is lead time number two is you can have
a breakup fee Associated now you can
imagine on the other side as a vendor
you're like this guy wants to put a
breakup fee on me my God this guy's
going to be sticky but at this point
when you have key components of the
business that are outsourced which I I
fundamentally don't do this anymore
because I have been screwed so many
times which is why I think that
Marketing sales delivery should be
inhouse to a business because it's just
too important but like Payment
Processing it's unlikely you're going to
start a payment processing but just to
be able to process your own payments
right there are some things that are
going to be outsourced you have to have
trust one is give the heads up two is
the breakup fee third is that you have
fees or fines associated with service
level agreements meaning you're going to
respond to us on this timeline you're
going to ship to us products or raw
materials on this schedule you're going
to get us Le or run this amount of ads
on this Cadence and when we think about
it that way that allows to say if you
don't do those things then you hedge the
amount of money that you would have lost
as a result of them not doing the work
with the fine associat it's basically a
hedge now if you have a vendor they're
going to try and decrease what that
amount of money is but them also having
transparency into understanding how
important their role is is again a
double-edged sword one is they'll
understand leverage on the other hand if
you get the term inside the deal in
terms of the cash required from them to
make sure that they're doing their job
you cover your downside finally and this
is a bit of like a advanced move if you
become significantly bigger than they
are or you're a huge percentage of their
business and they're still important to
you that's where things like Aqua hires
and Acquisitions can be very strategic
so you say hey under what circumstances
would you like to do what you do inside
of our company is there a way that we
could work together more permanently and
then you permanently align the
incentives if they're doing a good job
now if they're doing a terrible job then
you obviously want to do that but this
is how I think through we're reducing
risk with key vendors who are core to
how we make money and if they were to
disappear so too would our business and
so once this happens you get your
Superman
cape and then all of a sudden this
becomes a fist a Fist of Fury if you
will and then you can this this is a
dotted line because you can fly and you
realize that you didn't even need the
bridge to begin with because you're such
a good business owner and then you go
take the money and save the world or do
whatever Superman would do with $ 46.2
million which would probably be you know
try to double down and make a lot more
so that he could actually make a
difference in the world rather than just
his own life I've talked to over a
thousand business owners in person this
year I compiled the six most common
mistakes that prevent small businesses
from becoming big businesses and I made
a whole video about it so if you're
stuck this is for you